lastly if someone wants to pick up a
hoop but they're not confident maybe
you know as you talked about they're not
they don't feel good being in their body
or or just even having people see them
what would be the first step i think we
should try that with you oh my goodness
good answer this isn't about me this is
about youtube okay
well definitely first step is to um get
a big hoop um and a good place to start
is if you they could just do a google
search in their local city you can go to
the whoopinglife.com
yeah there's there's the
whoopinglife.com we have one of the
unusual ones that you can just go group
and make it half the size and boop you
can make it the whole size so you can
travel with it and take it and it's a
very good beginner yeah and there's a
dvd that comes with the hooping life dvd
there's my dvd also there's a lot of
how-to's purchase i do private skype
lessons so you can be anywhere in the
world and get a private from me
you know it really helps to have good
instruction at first because it can be
you know some people take to it
immediately and some people don't you
know so it's it's good to have someone
there to support you to be able to
visually tell you like oh move to the
left hold to the right you know kind of
thing yeah right but it's really trying
it yeah it's just jumping mate don't use
a kid's hoop make sure you get it yeah
make sure you have a nice big heavy
adult hoop yeah and talking about hoops
anna is making the first environmentally
friendly hoop yes the eco hoop um i've
got a whole new shipment of tubing
coming in that is 100 post-consumer
recycled tubing
so it used to be milk bottles now
they're hula hoops
and i've got two colors and they'll be
three different sizes so one of those
sizes will be you know good for for
people who are just starting out all the
way up through if you want to do like
all the off-body tricks and stuff like
that
yeah
and when anna gets the adult eco hoop
yes we're selling it immediately
no but it's the first time someone it's
very revolutionary what you're doing and
it was very hard and it yeah it's taken
years of of um banging my head against a
brick wall and almost giving up many
many times because
you think it would be simple you know
like oh it's just finding the material
and saying do this but so it's just i
can't even get into how complicated it
is still
and that's hooprevolution.revolution.com
you